since last year since last year you've  been encouraging Donald Trump to run for  president why well you know my thing it  winds up we're doing coke gets you going  this ya know I need it  ya know Trump  president hey no not on board early and  you said you've got to run for president  what happened I noticed that he tends to  at the time he tended to retweet anyone  who said hey you should run for  president right so here you twit it so I  told all my Twitter followers like let's  all just compliment him all the time and  say he should run for president cuz see  if we can get retweeted by him yeah and  did it work yeah he did do it yeah and  it's just like I guess he had the last  laugh  ironically campaigns for him yeah but  like how he's way ahead in the polls  yeah but you know what at the end of the  day like I am rooting for him because I  hate women so like I want is the most  anti woman yeah yeah no I want him to go  forth and prosperous yeah